you will notice I've drawn my graph two
things number one I've drawn an
unseasonably large that probably doesn't
surprise you at me cuz you know I love
the graphs but more interestingly I had
this huge portion of the graph that I
know I'm going to have to ignore okay
because it's negative which means when I
take the square root it doesn't exist
I'm not going to draw anything for that
part however in order to do this
accurately and point out some of the
important features of it it's actually
very important I have a gradient like
this if you make it too narrow you just
gonna start to understand problems as
you might have noticed okay so here's
what I'm going to notice ordinance order
it right ordinates are really really
important to me okay
because order this firstly these
negatives I know I can ignore them
secondly what's the easy ordinate to get
on this zeros right so I've got an
endpoint here and an endpoint here
that's the easy part
but there's one other ordinate or rather
a pair of ordinates
that are also really important to me
because I know when I take the square
root I know what think of me very good I
want the where horizontally the x value
am I going to go up to one because
clearly I'm below one at some point
which means you're going to get this
kind of behavior and then I'm above one
for other points which means you're
going to get this kind of bad so there's
a switch over and I want to know where
that is
okay now exactly as was mentioned it's
wherever Y it was one where y equals one
and where it intersects with that graph
now this point is actually really
important to me so I'm going to work it
out first okay if I want this graph to
equal one right I get this guy I get
this quadratic okay now if I just
rearrange it into general form you look
and you look and you look and you will
not be able to factorize that because it
rational roots let's quickly work out
what they are x equals minus B which is
1 plus or minus the square root of b
squared which is one minus 4ac which is
plus all over 2a which is 2 now this is
really important to me because whoops
this number is so important it gets
given them you guys remember how I said
things get names in proportion to their
significance how many people use and how
broadly it's used for the positive case
of this one plus the square root of 5/2
is a number called the golden ratio
mathematician see to five minutes five
right now you are some of you will know
this okay but for me what's important is
okay where is this what is the square
root of five roughly and it's gonna be
it's obviously between two and three
it's gonna be close to the two one two
three and three trip with you okay so
therefore what am i actual values here
what am I actually eyes can someone give
me maybe just went to someplace
what's one minus two squared five on two
and what's one plus the square root of
fun too I could tell give me actually
know what that's two three I know that
the golden ratio is about one point six
one eight right what's the other one
okay so the reason why these reported to
me is because I want to know roughly
where these happen right I know where
one is so therefore I should know where
one point six is okay so you see my arm
my scale is going to fail over here but
I can get roughly let's actually call it
say for example let's call it this point
and roughly that point okay you can draw
your horizontal scale better than I can
but I just need to know where they are
okay now being that at both these points
what is the videos of these points why
did I find them that's where the that's
where the order that is equal to one
right and I know what the square root of
one is it's one
since their and there are you happy with
that so I've got to pass through here
I'm going to go this way the pass
through here I'm going to go this way
how am I going to do it all of the
Ordnance here between 9:00 and 1:00
right if you take the square root of a
number between naught and 1 the square
root is going to be IR right the square
root of 1/4 is 1/2 which is higher so
therefore up here I'm going to look like
this I'm always going to be above that
graph but then once I pass over here
these ordinates are bigger than ones
right they're like 2 3 4 5 ok so the
square roots always going to stay
underneath it okay now it's therefore
going to do something like this okay
now I happen to know that's going to go
and it's not going to be like a log that
sort of gets shallower forever it kind
of is but not the way a log does and at
the same time I also know it's not going
to get steeper the question is how do I
do
very good so let me use some first I
should finish offering you let me use
our language of limits to see what's
going on when you say the limit as X
approaches infinity of the square root
of x squared minus X what is that right
now I know the x squared the X well
they're both reported terms when you get
to infinity how important is that minus
X really like and in comparison to x
squared not important at all you might
as well have that guy okay you might as
well now I don't need to know what
exactly that is
all I'm doing what that green is right
that's the absolute value of x yes the
absolute value of x it's great over here
is negative one right go down like that
and the absolute value of x on this side
is positive one you see should be going
off to a straight line basically okay
that's what sort of its approaching and
I know that because again it's kind of
like that tug-of-war thing remember like
this thing's obviously growing but the X
square the square root they claimed or
cancel each other out
it's just this minus X which is just
throwing us for a bit of a curve in
between okay and there's the graph yeah
I will okay so my argument was about
this guy all right this guy in here and
I was saying look just like we pull it
over yours in general the important term
is the leading term it's the one with
the degree attached to it
I don't care how big these guys are
going to be eventually this guy will
always be the you know the 800-pound
gorilla in the room he'll be the
significant term okay so being that as X
approaches infinity and negative
infinity this is really the term that
matters this term can be regarded as
trivial okay we can more or less ignore
it which leaves you with this which is
just the absolute value next I thanks
one of the definitions of the absolute
value of x and I know what the absolute
value of x in its gradient how it looks
negative one and one roughly